hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about uh blogging
and podcasts
as a means of enriching your
language learning sort of content
variety
and particularly as a step from beginner
material to the more difficult more
demanding material
um remember if you like these videos
please subscribe give me a like if you
like my video
um so yesterday i did a live stream
because this is sort of streak with
steve we're encouraging people to commit
to maintaining a streak at link
and so i have these live stream sessions
where i talk about a little bit about
what i'm doing
and uh so one of the things i've done
now is
through
a variety of reasons i discovered this
blog in croatian i discovered a
podcast in croatian at least a radio
station this is people i knew through
twitter or something i found in a book
and this really enriches my learning
material and these types of contents are
easier
than say you know
an audiobook ebook that i imported into
link
now
my next video will be
a discussion in french
so i warn you now there won't be
subtitles but there will be closed
captions
so you can import it into link if you
want
and this is a discussion with a person
called hugo cotton
who has a website called inner french
and we'll leave a link
and uh not today but next time
and he just gets on and talks about
things that are of interest him it could
be politics it could be i don't know i
haven't been following his thing
but it's very much appreciated as a
source of
medium difficulty french content and
it's real it's a real person talking
it's not something written for a learner
now there are podcasts
uh to help people learn a variety of
languages chinese korean you name it
where there's a mixture of english and
the target language and it's more aimed
at beginners so that's another option
but i tend not to use those
but i do find that these sort of blogs
and podcasts as intermediate learning
material are tremendously useful
because give you an insight they give
you an insight into the culture and
events in the country of the language
you're learning
and the level of difficulty is just that
next level so in my case with croatian
having gone through the mini stories i
found the ebook that i imported was a
little too difficult whereas i'm finding
that these podcasts and blogs are just
the right level
and i'm very happy to report that the
radio station i can't remember what it
was called
i downloaded some mp3 files i put them
on happy scribe and the transcription is
actually very good there's the odd funny
word but by and large good better than
was the case with
arabic so
even if it's a podcast with no audio
you can attempt to use these
transcription services
far better of course if is if a
transcript is provided
and uh
i actually have had two discussions with
bloggers one
uh does his at least the podcasters
one andrew
does his podcast in english he's a
canadian who lives
in korea
and we did an interview in english for
his uh channel
and he has a service where
he uh and i should get the link to his
in fact i'll make sure i provide that in
the description box so he uh
is based on subscription so you
subscribe to him for a year for ninety
dollars which i think is very reasonable
and he provides transcripts for all of
his
podcasts as well as some
exercises and other worksheet type
material
so i think this is obviously if you're
going to learn a language you're going
to end up spending some money in most
cases you may of course not you may
borrow books at the library and find
stuff on the internet and have language
exchanges and fine however
very often you will end up paying for a
tutor online you will end up buying a
book
you may eventually buy an audiobook or
an e-book you may have to pay for
transcription services or you pay for
this
podcast service that andrew has
i think hugo has a similar
program where
i think he provides his transcripts free
but then he has courses i mean these
people are putting their time and their
energy and their creativity into
creating these uh podcasts so they
certainly deserve to have their time and
effort compensated in some way but to me
that is an excellent kind of
input material
uh
it may lead to
online discussions with those tutors or
it may not but it fills a real need in
fact i would like to know
more about these kinds of materials if
you know about people who are podcasting
in this way just natural either
monologues or discussions
with or without transcripts ideally with
transcripts
please let me know we want to collect a
list of this kind of content and make
people aware
i think we had a
link central put out a
uh you know a twitter uh
tweet there about some
similar resources for portuguese
this is a growing area of content
creation
uh
unlike textbooks constantly renewing
itself more natural and i think it fills
a real need so
podcasts and blogs although they
obviously don't have audio are uh to my
mind the next step after we get through
the sort of beginner or
mini story type stage so the next part
the next video of mine in fact will be
my interview interview with hugo in
french
and i'm off to croatia and i will be
doing the next video when i figure out
how
i'm set up in croatia in terms of wi-fi
and so forth and so on so
bye for now
you